[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde la cinquième république
est-elle à bout de souffle il y a ceux
qui n'en veulent plus Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et les insoumis ce qui fait une de s'en
accommoder Marine Le Pen et le
rassemblement national ce qui s'en
réclame par filiation gaulliste les
républicains ce qui disent vouloir la
renaissance de la République sans
arriver à enrayer le dépérissement de la
Cinquième République Emmanuel Macron et
les parties qui gouvernent le pays l'air
du temps a changé depuis la Constitution
de 1958 complété en 1962 avec l'élection
présidentielle de Charles de Gaulle au
suffrage universel la verticalité du
pouvoir avec un exécutif fort est
aujourd'hui contesté la volonté
politique est mise en concurrence avec
les évolutions sociétales et le
populisme ambiant l'État et les
territoires entretiennent une Bizzbee
autour de la souveraineté et de la
décentralisation la démocratie
représentative a du plomb dans l'aile
depuis que l'abstention a entamé la
légitimité des élections las but not
list si vous me permettez cette
anglicisme la quasi simultanéité de
l'élection présidentielle et des
élections législatives et venues
brouiller l'orientation et l'efficacité
de la politique gouvernementale nous
allons chercher avec mes invités à
discerner ce qu'il reste de la Cinquième
République je vais le faire avec vous
enlevade professeur des universités
juristes Jérôme Guedj député nupes
Dominique Régnier professeur à Sciences
Po président de fond d'Apple Henri
Guaino homme politique et séistes
[Musique]
Emmanuel Macron a été réélu en avril
2022 pour un deuxième mandat les
élections législatives qui ont suivi ne
lui accorde qu'une majorité relative à
l'Assemblée nationale au-delà de
l'actuel brouhaha parlementaire la
Cinquième République vous paraît-elle
vieillissante voire en fin de course
Anne Leval
ma réponse sera non et je dirais que il
n'y a qu'en France qu'on se pose la
question du vieillissement des textes
constitutionnels nous avons en France
une maladie c'est que nous adorons les
constitutions la constitutionnaliste que
je suis devrait s'en réjouir parce que
nous prêtons aux constitutions des
vertus extraordinaires moyennant quoi
nous avons le recordman mondial le
record mondial du nombre de
constitutions depuis la fin du XVIIIe
siècle puisque nous avons tout
expérimenté nous avons eu 15
constitutions et nous adorons en changer
et même lorsque vous venons d'en adopter
une nous aiderons l'idée de la réviser
moi c'est vrai que je cite souvent un
exemple à mes étudiants certes le régime
n'a rien à voir et l'état non plus mais
les États-Unis ont le même texte
constitutionnel depuis 1787 il a été
révisé 27 fois nous sommes à la 15e
constitution et cette quinzième
Constitution a été révisée 24 fois donc
ça signifie que nous pensons que réviser
la Constitution peut améliorer les
choses et je crois que c'est prêté trop
de crédit à la règle juridique il n'y a
pas de raison de réviser dès lors que la
Constitution ne paralyse pas le système
a l'impression que ce soit le cas où on
va rentrer dans le détail mais sur le
diagnostic chacun d'entre vous Dominique
Régnier sur le diagnostic oui à bout de
souffle non je reprendrai volontiers
bien sûr sans le répéter à mon compte ce
que vient de dire elle Levade
j'ajouterai que il y a un certain
malaise que l'on peut éprouver avoir des
responsables politiques
projetés de réviser les institutions
comme s'il s'agissait pour eux
d'expliquer les raisons de leur
difficulté ou de leurs échecs comme si
au fond tous les moyens mis à leur
disposition leur permettait pas
d'accomplir la mission que leur avait
été confiée et au fond
une façon de dire écoutez si on pouvait
aménager tout cela autrement je serais
bien plus efficace donc c'est une forme
de fuite devant
mais pour vous elle est vieillie à bout
de souffle ou d'une conséquence je
la conclusion de ce que je viens de dire
là comme c'est un argument c'est que non
non Jérôme Guedj c'est oui ou non
est-ce qu'elle vous paraît à bout de
souffle aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'à 64 ans on est à bout de
souffle c'est bien que c'est l'âge
auquel on veut mettre à la retraite les
uns et les autres moi je pourrais
prendre la question et en rebondissant
sur ce que sur ce qui vient d'être dit
je crois que cette appétence française
pour
la chose constitutionnelle c'est le
prolongement d'une certaine manière du
goût des Français pour la politique
c'est parce qu'ils sont passionnés par
le débat politique que il se passionne
aussi pour les règles du jeu et ça doit
pas les exonérer ça doit pas nous
exonérer aussi de questionner la manière
dont on joue parce que il y a les du jeu
mais on peut avoir les meilleures règles
du jeu et si les joueurs sont pas bons
sur le terrain de foot le match est
assez insipide et le point de de départ
de toutes ces questionsnements c'est
une forme de désenchantement
démocratique de défiance à l'endroit du
politique et donc la question est de
savoir est-ce que c'est la règle du jeu
qui explique cette défiance ou est-ce
que c'est le contenu de l'offre
politique la manière de faire vivre le
débat politique je pense que la réponse
est les deux évidemment mais pour
répondre directement à la question il y
a quand même par rapport
l'histoire de la Constitution on est en
octobre 2022 il y a quasiment 60 ans
presque jour pour jour que le référendum
sur l'élection du Président de la
République au suffrage universel
consacré ce qui était prévu comme tel la
primauté du président or aujourd'hui on
a probablement un essoufflement de cette
figure là dans la cinquième république
la primauté du président de la
République est devenue une
toute-puissance du président de la
République et peut-être que ça asphyxie
une partie du débat politique
vous vous êtes pas d'accord ou avec ça
vous pensez que je ferai de deux ou
trois observations la première c'est
qu'il faut pas imputer à la constitution
ce qui est imputable au désordre de la
société toutes les démocraties
occidentales sont en crise toutes les
démocraties en crise profonde bon
regardez enfin les États-Unis on a pris
d'Assoul Capitole ça c'est pas la preuve
que la démocratie américaine se porte
bien c'est un pays qui est fracturant en
deux
l'Allemagne elle tombe bien que mal elle
sait se sentirait avec des coalitions
qui deviennent de plus en plus
improbables l'Italie n'en parlons pas
l'Espagne n'a pas de major il y a pas de
majorité pour l'instant d'élection en
élection on n'arrive pas à trouver des
vrais majorités là aussi on est obligé
de sentirer avec des coalitions
improbables voilà la France est pas une
exception c'est ce sont nos sociétés qui
sont d'abord en crise alors après les
les institutions peuvent aggraver les
choses elles peuvent elles peuvent venir
rendre le politique impuissant c'était
le cas dans des régimes qui ont précédé
on sait comment a fini la Quatrième
République quand on tombe dans un régime
rassembler c'est à dire qu'il y a plus
de bien plus de rentrer dans le détail
il y a plus de possibilités de de de
dissolution de l'Assemblée vis-à-vis
seulement indépendant et un poste un
poste son point de vue ça peut très mal
finir c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
fait la 5e République pour laquelle le
général de Gaulle a posé cette condition
quand on l'a rappelé au pouvoir en 58
c'est on change d'abord les institutions
mais je crois que la Constitution de la
Cinquième République elle a permis à un
pays qui est difficile à gouverner
d'être gouverné alors après on peut être
bien ou mal gouverné mais ça nous
renvoie non pas seulement aux
institutions mais aux personnes aux
hommes personnels politiques et donc à
la société qui génère ce personnel qui
engendre ce personnel politique voilà
après on a depuis 1962 on a beaucoup
déréglé nos institutions donc c'est pas
la Cinquième République en soi qui est
en qui est en cause mais le quinquennat
le non renouvellement du mandat
présidentiel le le ce qu'on a fait avec
les restrictions sur l'article sur le
49-3 etc on déréglé profond nos
institutions donc la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est est-ce qu'il faut
essayer de de les régler de nouveau
enfin nous retrouver un équilibre à
l'intérieur voilà mais mais je crois pas
du tout à l'idée
que la question du pouvoir présidentiel
la verticalité soit aujourd'hui des des
arguments décisifs je et une remarque
quand même sur la réforme des
institutions on parle toujours de la
France les Anglais en ont fait une en
2011 bon jusque là le alors il y avait
pas de cours suprême maintenant il y en
a une mais jusque là le Premier ministre
pouvait dissoudre le le Parlement
maintenant il ne peut le dissoudre
qu'avec l'accord du Parlement enfin la
chambre
oui mais c'est très intéressant parce
que ils ont ils ont déréglé leur système
constitutionnel on a vu qu'on a vu le
résultat au moment du brexit
c'est-à-dire que ils ont créé un régime
d'assemblée en réalité voilà donc alors
justement mais il y a quand même quelque
chose qui interroge aujourd'hui
en novembre 58 et en juin 88 tant le
général de Gaulle que François
Mitterrand se sont retrouvés avec des
majorités relatives les gouvernements
d'alors ont fait leur travail sans
grande entraves alors qu'aujourd'hui on
annonce parents anticipation l'impasse
politique qu'est-ce qui a changé et
qu'en pensez-vous alors Jérôme Guedj
ce qui a changé c'est là que j'ai un
désaccord avec Henri Guaino c'est que
peut-être que cette aspiration ce besoin
de verticalité correspondait à la
période de la Cinquième République ou de
sa fondation et des présidents de la
République a commencé par le général de
Gaulle qui l'ont incarné je pense que un
des mots de notre société c'est que
d'ailleurs c'est pas un des mots c'est
un des enjeux une année de challenges
c'est d'introduire par opposition à la
verticalité quelque chose de plus
horizontal de plus participatif et que
la fonction
iconique
petit père de la nation Jupiter pour
reprendre les différents termes qui
étaient utilisés pour caractériser les
présidents de la République ne colle
peut-être pas tout à fait avec l'air du
temps ce qui veut pas dire pour autant
qu'il y a pas un besoin de d'autorité
d'organisation d'une figure autour de
laquelle la vie politique s'organise
mais pour répondre à vos questions
est-ce que vous voulez dire
que les présidents qui ont suivi dans la
cinquième république n'habite pas le
pouvoir et l'autorité comme l'habité par
exemple le général de Gaulle je suis sûr
que ça ferait très plaisir que je dis
cela Henri Guaino mais je ferai pas
c'est un jour ni évidemment à François
Mitterrand ni même Ajac Chirac ou
Nicolas Sarkozy ou François ou François
Hollande parce que encore une fois ils
ont accompagné aussi des évolutions de
la société pour moi le point de de
réponse à votre question c'est que
aujourd'hui au moment où Emmanuel Macron
est accompagne une vie accompagnée par
une majorité relative il y a une
promesse un peu
orthogonale une sorte de d'oxymore qui
était je vais chercher à produire du
compromis de la coproduction avec avec
le Parlement on a même cru que c'était
une forme de réémergence d'un parlement
fait là où la Cinquième République
intrinsèquement c'était un
parlementarisme rationalisé jolis mots
pour dire un cas de nassage de la vie de
la vie parlementaire
et que donc cette espérance d'un
parcelle d'un parlementarisme de fait
elle se heurte quand même au fait qu'il
y a une sorte de rémanence on continue à
fonctionner comme si il y avait un femme
un fait majoritaire qui s'appliquait
aujourd'hui
les téléspectateurs qui nous écoutent
Dominique Régnier est-ce que les
nouveaux remaniements à venir
vont aller vers une cinquième bise vers
une sixième vers une quatrième parce que
les gens s'interrogent si les politiques
considèrent qu'on est plus dans une
cinquième république classique et
orthodoxe on se demande où on va je vais
pas pouvoir vous aider beaucoup mais par
contre c'est votre domaine la science
politique donc là je peux pas vous aider
beaucoup mais par contre il y a un
aspect important et il était présent
dans la question que vous posiez là et
ça ça rejoint cette question là on ne
peut pas faire l'économie de comme
d'ailleurs le disait Henri Guaino on
peut pas faire l'économie de ce qu'est
la société et d'être une tension qu'il a
parcourt je prends un exemple très
simple la différence entre la période
première je dirais 58 jusque grosso modo
au milieu des années 90 et puis depuis
la différence c'est que nous sommes dans
un régime aujourd'hui et c'est pas le
régime qui était en cause où les
décisions à prendre sont presque toutes
des décision à mon avis impopulaire il
est très difficile aujourd'hui de
fabriquer du consensus lorsque vous avez
une injonction que je considère moi
comme légitime et recevable à
l'équilibre budgétaire dans une
situation très dégradée donc c'est pas
du tout le même monde de ce point de vue
mais ça ne sont pas les institutions qui
ne donneront la réponse je ne vois pas
ce qui fait que nous aurons un consensus
parlementaire ou une majorité même
présidentielle c'est là qu'à mon avis se
présente le problème de l'élection
présidentielle au suffrage universel
aujourd'hui à quel moment le peuple
français serait majoritairement d'accord
pour élire un pouvoir notamment le
président afin de restaurer les
équilibres budgétaires dans le pays a
besoin pour que ça souveraineté soit
plein air je pense que c'est
contradictoires dans les termes
désormais ça n'était pas évidemment au
départ c'est fondateur c'est puissant le
général fond de la légitimité du régime
là dessus la refonte dans l'élection du
chef d'État sera Universal universel
direct la gauche au pouvoir avec
Mitterrand ça ça achève de montrer que
tout donc là est complètement en racine
de la société y compris à gauche donc ça
fonctionne très bien sauf que toute la
première période c'est de la
distribution de ressources c'est du
partage et il est beaucoup plus facile
de faire un consensus même sous la forme
d'une majorité pour partager pour
distribuer que pour annoncer des
nouvelles extrêmement désagréables
d'ailleurs au point qu'on n'ose pas les
annoncer alors à leva j'insiste quand
même à votre avis ce qui se passe
actuellement
ça reste la cinquième ou Sarah rappelle
la quatrième
tout dépend ce qu'on met derrière le mot
Cinquième République mais vous observez
j'explique la Cinquième République c'est
d'abord un texte évidemment et ce texte
établit un certain équilibre
on pourrait même dire un certain
déséquilibre structurel qui a été voulu
d'emblée cela dit il y a aucun régime
qui met en place où que ce soit dans le
monde un équilibre parfait pour une
raison simple c'est qu'une constitution
qu'elle est 200 ans ou comme aujourd'hui
produits 64 ans elle est en général
conçue par le constituant pour s'adapter
à ce qu'on pourrait considérer comme les
spécificités du pays il y a un
tempérament français je prends un cas
précis l'élection du président suffrage
universel direct que l'on cite toujours
nous ne sommes pas le seul État au monde
à le pratiquer mais assurément chez nous
il a pu provoquer des phénomènes
politiques qui sont liées non pas au
fait que la Constitution prévoit cette
élection au suffrage universel direct
mais au fait que la conjonction entre
cette règle et le tempérament français
fait que c'est l'élection reine de notre
jeu institutionnel après la cinquième
république elle a eu une vie et une vie
pas si longue que ça à l'aune de ce
qu'on peut voir dans d'autres États et
cette vie elle est évidemment très
étroitement liée aux équilibres
politiques j'observe que par exemple
alors que pendant un certain nombre
d'années on évoquait cette période comme
étant à la fois improbable et pas
complètement
dévastatrice sur le plan institutionnel
on ne parle quasiment plus de
cohabitation évidemment parce que
effectivement depuis la mise en place du
quinquennat la coïncidence des dates des
élections on imagine plus qu'une
cohabitation plus survenir d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière la réforme du
quinquennat et l'inversion du calendrier
a même été faite pour ça pour autant moi
ce que je vois c'est que la Cinquième
République est-ce que est-ce que c'était
la 5e République sous la cohabitation
ben oui en tout cas les institutions ont
tenu le choc et elles ont permis à cette
configuration politique que jamais
personne n'avait imaginé en 58 et
certainement pas le général de Gaulle
elles ont permis que le régime
fonctionne quand je dis fonctionne il
n'a pas fonctionné comme entre 58 et 62
ou comme après 62 simplement le
gouvernement au sens générique du terme
n'a pas été paralysé quand je dis le
gouvernement c'est le gouvernement du
pays et donc et bien d'une manière qui
n'était pas du tout conforme à l'esprit
initial du texte on a pu prendre des
décisions c'est à dire voter des lois
adopter des actes réglementaires avoir
une justice qui fonctionne etc moi le
regard de la constitutionnaliste que je
suis il est attaché à cela une
république une monarchie un empire
fonctionne tant que on empêche pas le ce
qui résulte du choix politique d'un
peuple à un moment donné de faire
fonctionner les institutions et de
prendre des décisions politiques après
ça peut être plus ou moins laborieux
évidemment que c'est plus simple pour
ceux qui gouvernent quand ils ont une
majorité absolue qu'une majorité
relative mais Jérôme Guedj parlait de la
rationalisation du parlementarisme
corset ou pas corsé par exemple le
modèle allemand consiste toujours je
rappelle qu'en Allemagne une motion de
censure ne peut aboutir qu'à la
condition que les députés
désignent un chancelier alternatif
on va rentrer dans le détail quand même
des mesures
mais
la cohabitation toute petite divergence
sur le fait qu'elle était pas dans
l'esprit des institutions alors elle
était pas dans l'esprit du général de
Gaulle pour une raison simple c'est
qu'il aurait démissionné est-ce qu'il a
pas de probablement avec Valérie Giscard
j'ai eu cette idée générale de Gaulle
non
mais d'une certaine manière
c'était sa façon de de gérer sa relation
non pas à la Constitution mais au peuple
français c'était mais moi j'ai eu cette
conversation au moment de la première la
première cohabitation avec Michel Debré
Michel Debré m'avait rappelé très
justement que premièrement c'est une
constitution parlementaire la Cinquième
République est un régime parlementaire
c'est à dire si vous n'avez pas de
majorité au Parlement bien vous ne
pouvez pas gouverner librement voilà
c'est c'est donc
à quoi Michel Debré tenait d'ailleurs
beaucoup et il m'avait il m'avait dit
mais la la la cohabitation elle est
inscrite dans les institutions c'est à
dire que un jour ou l'autre il est
normal que cela puisse arriver et
d'ailleurs ça c'est plutôt bien passé ça
s'est bien passé alors d'abord parce que
les acteurs
ont très bien joué le on est très bien
joué le jeu parce que Mitterrand a été
sur ce point-là parfait c'est-à-dire
qu'il a redéfini le le son terrain
périmètre de des compétences
présidentielles en allant un peu au-delà
la lettre de la Constitution mais en
respectant aussi les la tradition qui
s'était qui c'était c'était imposée et
et ça s'est très bien passé ensuite il y
avait qui avait subi la première
cohabitation à un vécu à son tour la
cohabitation et il l'a très très bien
géré dans le cadre communityan avait
avait défini là où les choses se
compliquent ces premièrement que que on
fait la réforme du quinquennat qui a
déréglé ce système ce qui ne veut pas
dire d'ailleurs qu'il y aura pas de
cohabitation on voit bien que c'est pas
impossible on voit bien que ça n'est pas
impossible et alors la deuxième le
deuxième dérèglement il vient parce que
le quinquennat n'est pas une erreur si
c'est une faute c'est une faute le
quinquennat plus l'inversion du
calendrier
juste vous êtes tous d'accord là-dessus
mais alors si vous êtes tous d'accord
là-dessus je vais vous la je vous laisse
finir après et si vous êtes d'accord que
le quinquennat et l'inversion sont des
erreurs pourquoi ça a été fait ah parce
que finalement si ça correspond à rien
ça veut dire et alors dites-le c'est
l'usage terrible qu'on fait de la
révision constitutionnelle c'est à dire
usage tactique inscrite dans un
calendrier dans un calendrier
c'est-à-dire on fait de la petite
politique avec de grandes choses qui ne
devraient pas être mêlées à ce genre de
manœuvre et donc vous pensez qu'il faut
alors là dessus
plus les mandats sont courts mieux c'est
ce qui est une erreur parce que plus le
monde va vite et plus il faut que la
politique au contraire qu'on pense la
rapidité des laquelle fonctionne la
société à laquelle vont les événements
par un temps plus long on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on est on est
complètement étouffé par ce temps court
bon ça c'est la première chose
dans la constitution de 62 c'est à dire
en septennat
autant de fois
ah oui et quand le phase d'ailleurs par
l'article 11 ça a beaucoup souvent
beaucoup plus de la provocation
une seconde pourquoi ça pourquoi ça ça
c'est déréglé à la fois à cause du
quinquennat et parce que pendant les
cohabitations avant la fin des années 90
il y avait il y avait deux camps il y
avait une bipolarité il y avait des
parties organisées et que dans tous les
pays occidentaux les parties se sont
décomposés c'est-à-dire qui et quand ils
se sont pas décomposés formellement ils
se sont décomposés à l'intérieur il y a
des fractures au sein du parti
conservatoire anglais du parti
républicain Parti démocrate aux
États-Unis et en France en particulier
donc aujourd'hui si ça ne si c'est aussi
compliqué c'est parce que le paysage est
partisan est complètement important
à la durée du mandat des parlementaires
on va passer aux autres questions mais
sur le moi je reviens là-dessus sur le
septénard parce que moi je vais vous
dire pourquoi je vais vous dire non et
je vais vous dire pourquoi on pensait
que le quinquennat allait produire des
effets qu'il n'a pas produit et on n'a
pas vu les effets qu'il avait qu'il
allait produire et je pense que le
retour au septaina d'ailleurs quand
Henri Guaino dit je veux revenir à la
constitution de 1962 nous ne sommes plus
en 1962 donc je ne sais pas ce que la
constitution de 1962 produirait si nous
la réappliquons à l'état aujourd'hui et
donc je pense que sans doute le
quinquennat n'est pas une bonne formule
mais rien ne dit que le passage à
insecté n'a améliorer les choses donc
arrêtons de bricoler moi je ne suis pas
favorable à ce qu'on leur bricolage à 7
ans ou pas Dominique René sur ce point
précis
je me réponds je crois qu'il faut et
c'est quand même téléspectateurs doivent
imaginer que les réponses ne sont pas
automatiques et ne sont pas simples
j'introduis une autre variable pour
répondre à votre question tout à l'heure
je parlais de l'époque mais aujourd'hui
être président de la République en
France vu l'évolution de l'appareillage
administratif et de ce dont on se mêle
l'État en France c'est inévitablement
c'est quelqu'un qui va se mêler de tout
et assez mal et qui va d'ailleurs y
compris parce qu'il se mêlera de tout
entrer en contradiction avec l'image de
l'institution
issue du suffrage universel total direct
le président Sarkozy faisait pareil je
pense que une des conditions du retour
par exemple au septennat mais je pense
que c'est une des conditions
fondamentales quel que soit sans touche
institution c'est de réduire
l'importance de l'État dans ce qu'il a à
opérer au sein de la société et de
partager davantage de pouvoir avec la
société civile les entreprises les élus
locaux enfin un président plus souverain
moins manager ce serait moins
contradictoire plus horizontale merci ça
c'est le quinquennat qui était en cause
il a fait du du président de la
République un super Premier ministre et
la rupture elle est bien là le deuxième
le deuxième mandat de Jacques Chirac
s'inscrivait dans la foulée du de son
septennat donc ça n'a pas été un vrai ça
n'a pas été un vrai quinquennat
tandis que à partir de Nicolas Sarkozy
on entre dans cette période dans cette
nouvelle cette nouvelle ère qui est
celle du quinquennat avec un super
Premier ministre en ayant en même temps
un premier ministre vous a entendu
collaborateur on vous a entendu Henri
Guaino on vous a entendu là-dessus on
vous a entendu sauf en cohabitation
[Musique]
prolongeons le débat l'extrême gauche
avec notamment les insoumis l'extrême
droite avec le rassemblement national
dispose respectivement d'un important
groupe parlementaire mais quand on est
un observateur on se dit mais qu'ils en
font quoi qu'est-ce que cherchent au
fond Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'est-ce que
cherche au fond marine Le Pen sinon
finalement à faire d'émotion de censure
par opportunité Jérôme Guedj mais vous
motiverez d'abord contester la
présentation politique des choses dans
l'histoire politique française et je
pars je parle sous le contrôle des mines
connaisseurs l'extrême gauche c'est pas
la gauche radicale que la France
insoumise moi je suis socialiste donc je
suis pas là pour faire l'exégète de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de et de la France
insoumise mais dire que cette gauche
ratique Allah c'est l'extrême gauche
dans la tradition politique française
c'est des gens qui les institutions qui
sont pour l'abolition de la propriété
privée et la confiscation des moyens de
production c'est pas tout à fait le
programme de la France
moi je suis socialiste moi je suis
radicalement socialiste et qui participe
à une coalition qui s'appelle la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale non mais je veux dire ça son
importance parce que ça procède aussi de
la manière dont on aborde les choses ce
qui m'amène à répondre à votre question
je pense que ça ne correspond pas à la
réalité de la vie politique française
l'extrême droite elle est un invariant
d'échelle assez identifiable
il faut prolonger le raisonnement là
à condition de prolonger la parallèle
c'est à dire que vous ne trouverez pas
dans le programme ni dans les propos de
Marine Le Pen de remise en cause de la
République de remise en cause de la
démocratie et de remise en cause des
libertés vous y trouverez des idées
différentes la préférence nationale est
une atteinte à ce qu'elle identité
républicaine du pays voilà comme vous le
savez oui mais on n'a jamais considéré
que Mayotte se trouvait gérer dans par
des normes c'est un peu une
démonstration par la marge je pourrais
vous dire que toute fonction publique
est fondée sur la préférence nationale
tout recrutement de la fonction publique
donc c'est massif non non mais
simplement sur le je crois que nous
avons affaire à deux expressions du
populisme un peu plus libre de gauche un
peu plus de droite mais ça ça légitime
votre question c'est à dire que au fond
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas alors ils ont
des positions très différentes mais ils
n'ont pas véritablement
d'espoir de de prendre de pouvoir
maintenant mais tous ceux qui peut
éroder les institutions dégradées de
climat politique créé aux prochaines
échéances une situation politiquement de
rupture leur est favorable et donc c'est
une
vous le savez on le sait tous des
parties de gouvernement sont à la
ramasse sans exception ce qui furent et
même le même la République en marche
aujourd'hui enfin le Renaissance étant
difficulté on l'a vu au législative et
donc il y a cette idée que le momentum
c'est les parties populistes et c'est
une réalité on voit dans nombreux
évocraties je vais pas reprendre la
liste faite juste titre tout à l'heure
par Henri Guaino donc c'est c'est ça qui
nous rend les choses difficiles et je
dirais que ce que nous allons nous
faisons l'expérience depuis les
législatives c'est que nous ne sommes
pas un pays à culture
parlementariste on le voit bien il y a
une majorité relative formidable
regardons comment on va fabriquer
ensemble des majorités d'idées de
compromis un effort si je peux me
permettre
le questionnement c'est que cette
absence de culture parlementariste elle
procède de la pratique aujourd'hui le
défi aurait pu être relevé tout à fait
différemment moi j'ai entendu dans son
discours de politique générale Elisabeth
borne dire ben nous allons essayer de
faire du compromis la prononcer 25 fois
le mot bon sauf que la réalité de la
recherche le compromis ça peut pas être
hémiplégique ça peut pas être le
compromis avec moi-même et avec mes
seuls mes seules idées et sur les textes
qui sont arrivés depuis le début de
cette mandature il y a pas eu cette idée
de d'essayer de construire y compris des
majorités de projets ponctuels sur tel
sur tel ou tel texte à tel point
d'ailleurs que on dégaine maintenant à
tour de bras le 49-3 sur les
dispositions budgétaires d'accord mais
comment régler nous est à côté je vais
lui poser cette question qui me paraît
intéressante tous les présidents sous la
Cinquième République on remplit leur
fonction mais tous avec le souci d'être
vraiment les mettre du pays pourquoi
votre avis ce procès qui est fait
aujourd'hui procès d'intention instruit
à l'égard d'Emmanuel Macron d'abord je
pense que la plupart des présidents
n'ont pas rempli leurs fonctions en
essayant d'être les maîtres du pays
pas du pays
je voulais que je vous cite une dernière
citation de Mitterrand avant de pour les
dernières années qu'est-ce que la
Cinquième République sinon la possession
du pouvoir par un seul homme et qu'il a
exercé oui mais ça vous savez il avait
dit aussi la Cinquième République était
dangereuse avant moi elle redeviendra
après moi oui mais oui
bien qu'ils ont tous exercés
de cette façon d'abord parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses qui m'intéressait pas
on économie ça n'intéressait pas par
exemple pour le social ça intéressait
pas non plus énormément il s'intéressait
à la géopolitique s'intéresser à la
culture et il a pesé sur la
sur la politique culturelle beaucoup
plus que sur la politique économique et
la politique économique il l'a faite en
fonction de l'idée qu'il se faisait de
la nécessité de raccrocher l'Allemagne à
l'Europe parce qu'il avait des souvenirs
des souvenirs douloureux de
l'entre-deux-guer mais Emmanuel Macron
pourquoi ce procès d'intention
aujourd'hui je sais pas si c'est un
procès d'intention c'est bon François
Hollande François Hollande a certaine
façon très très débonnaire et pas
toujours adéquate sont son mandat pour
être gentil
manuel Macron l'exerce avec sa
personnalité et après tout sa
personnalité alors on la connaissait
moins bien il y a 5 ans mais maintenant
là on a vu pendant un mandat et
l'arithmétique électorale a fait qui se
retrouve à nouveau président mais les
gens savaient très bien enfin les
Français savaient très bien au fond qui
il était donc et moi je ne compare pas
il est pas comparable à son prédécesseur
ni à François Mitterrand ni Georges
Pompidou venait Giscard d'Estaing enfin
c'est c'est
comparable c'est la façon dont on exerce
là je rejoins Jérôme Guedj c'est que la
façon dont on exerce le pouvoir elle est
elle est peut-être permise par les
institutions mais elle n'est pas elle
n'est pas contrainte par les
institutions c'est pas les institutions
qui font le caractère de de et la façon
d'exercer le pouvoir d'Emmanuel Macron
Anne le van est-ce que vous percevez ce
procès d'intention qui est fait à
l'égard d'Emmanuel Macron
l'observateur que je suis en tant que
journaliste l'observe alors procès
d'intention je sais pas critique oui
mais je ne connais pas un président de
la République en tout cas sur les
derniers mandats qui alors qu'il était
en fonction n'est pas été agonie de
critiques voire parfois d'injures pour
être souvent
d'ailleurs oui mais la période des
sondages est plus récente à cet égard là
pour être en général adulée aussitôt
qu'il a quitté son qu'il a terminé son
mandat en revanche et là je partage
vraiment ce que vient de dire Henri
Guaino je crois que le texte
constitutionnel c'est un cadre à
l'intérieur de ce cadre chacun est
appelé à se mouvoir avec sa personnalité
sa conception de la fonction conception
de la fonction qui d'ailleurs évolue
bien souvent alors que celui qui vient
d'être élu l'exerce il y a contexte
politique aucun doute là-dessus mais il
y a aussi le contexte j'allais dire
extrapolitique françois Hollande fait
campagne sur une présidente normale je
pense que le quinquennat est notamment
la séquence des attentats lui interdit
d'être un président normal on peut pas
être un président normal quand en 2015
on a Charlie Hebdo puis l'attaque du du
Stade de France et du Bataclan et
qu'ensuite on est obligé de mettre en
place l'état d'urgence à cet égard la
réunion du Congrès du 16 novembre 2015
est un moment
d'exacerbation salutaire non seulement
de la fonction présidentielle mais aussi
du jeu institutionnel et c'est
extrêmement fort je suis d'ailleurs très
surprise toujours que ça n'est pas été
présenté comme tel c'est le moment où on
dit dès lors qu'on peut réunir ensemble
tous les parlementaires le gouvernement
le président de la République 36 heures
après un attentat majeur la République
est debout et je n'ai pas besoin de
recourir à l'article 16 donc je veux
dire je crois que à aucun un moment et
personne ne change fragf heureusement
pour lui en 2012 il imagine qu'il va se
retrouver dans des circonstances où il
sera obligé de faire ça il avait dit que
lui ne souhaitait pas recourir au
Congrès Emmanuel Macron élu dis-moi
Geoffrey une réunion du Congrès chaque
année les gilets jaunes terminées les
réunions du Congrès donc voilà tout ça
tout ça évolue et moi je trouve qu'on a
l'extraordinaire chance que justement il
y ait cette liberté laisser au jeu
politique et aux circonstances pourquoi
je dis ça on évoque évidemment depuis
tout à l'heure la cohabitation et la
place respective au sein de l'exécutive
du président et des gouvernements et je
me souviens encore à chaque fois qu'on
parle de révision on dit soit il faut
supprimer l'article 20 qui dit le
Gouvernement détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation parce que c'est
pas vrai c'est le président qui le fait
ou bien au contraire d'autres disent
mais le président viole la Constitution
il ne respecte pas le fait que et ben ça
dépend et le choix que fait le président
de la République de tel ou tel pour
exercer en fonction de Premier ministre
joue évidemment un rôle déterminant à
cet égard et tous les présidents de la
République qui ont eu plusieurs premiers
ministres même celui qui n'en a eu qu'un
dans la personne de Nicolas Sarkozy
c'est très bien selon qu'il choisit
Pierre Paul ou Jacques ou Jacqueline que
tout ça va pouvoir conduire à un
équilibre au sein de l'exécutif
différent donc heureusement qu'on a
cette liberté là alors là on reproche
souvent à la cinquième de corseter le
Parlement mais je ne comprends pas cette
volonté de corps sauter les institutions
par une réforme donc encore une fois on
ne sait même pas si elle permettra de
faire ce que l'on en veut alors domicile
pour avancer un peu dans ce débat et
quand même essayer de voir ce qui se
passe de Gaulle confié à l'imperfite
qu'il avait vrai pour une monarchie
républicaine et non pas pour une
République monarchique est-ce que il
s'agit que d'une nostalgie ou est-ce
qu'il y a une réalité au regard de ce
qu'est la France jacobine colbertiste
républicaine etc
tout ça ce mêle sans doute à la
nostalgie voire au deuil d'une grandeur
et d'une puissance disparue donc c'est
quand même très lié aussi c'est un pays
qui vit depuis des décennies
des épreuves de déclassement
je crois que ça compte beaucoup dans le
dans le malheur national des
déclassements et pas déclin des
classements non parce que
ce serait un débat mais il est naturel
que de des puissances émergentes
prennent rond c'est naturel que l'un de
la Chine et d'autres encore jouent un
rôle important c'est le contraire qui
était choquant donc du coup évidemment
on se trouve il y a d'autres raisons et
peut-être que c'est aussi une forme de
déclin par la démographie par
l'affaiblissement mais je crois que
c'est très lié à cette idée là et d'une
certaine manière nous avons pris
l'habitude depuis très longtemps et
c'est pas une mauvaise habitude
simplement il faut être à la hauteur de
cette habitude de trouver dans le lieu
central du pouvoir en particulier chez
nous parce il y a aussi la dimension moi
que je trouve très importante et
problématiques de la parisisation
parisienne du pouvoir c'est à Paris
c'est pas n'importe quelle ville c'est
pas n'importe quel je dirais effet sur
l'ensemble de la société mais d'un
pouvoir en majesté est capable de et le
point je terminais par là mais le point
qui rend compliqué et qui arrive ensuite
au procès dont vous parliez pour le
président actuel
nous allons vers des surenchères
constantes en matière de procès de nos
présidents parce que tout ce que nous
avons dit jusqu'ici en raccourci les
mandats on se charge de plus en plus de
choses on met de plus en plus en avant
le président puisque par définition il a
le même terme à peu près que que le
reste de son équipe et donc il y a une
personnalisation qui est déjà dans les
institutions mais qui seradicalisent par
ce fait là que la société elle-même
radicalise par les réseaux sociaux etc
et donc c'est un régime en fait je parle
pas du régime conditionnel c'est un
rythme intenable en réalité et d'autant
plus que dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
dans la France d'aujourd'hui
on tente à confondre moi je l'observe
souvent
popularité qui n'est pas une contrainte
constitutionnelle et légitimité si bien
que déjà aujourd'hui chacun aura noté
quelques mois après l'élection
présidentielle on entend énoncé des
candidatures pour la prochaine alors ça
c'est une des conséquences de la réforme
de 2008 elle pose beaucoup de problèmes
à ce sujet mais ça veut dire aussi que
déjà la société française est invitée à
regarder ce président qu'elle vient de
réélire comme quelqu'un qui s'en va oui
alors Jérôme Guedj je voudrais avoir
votre avis sur ce point-là mais le
prolonger également parce qu'il se dit
beaucoup à gauche y compris à l'extrême
gauche
que il y aurait un pouvoir revigorré par
les territoires est-ce que vous pensez
que quelque chose peut se produire à ce
niveau pour redonner un second souffle à
la vie politique française alors il y a
deux questions les deux je le redis pour
être clair pour moi le cœur du problème
dans la formulation que vous disiez de
Gaulle monarchie républicaine ou
République monarchique dans les deux cas
il y a une monarchie trop c'est à dire
que je pense que cette monarchie
présidentielle se glissement de la
primauté du président qui me pose pas de
problème à la toute-puissance du
Président je pense qu'on crève de ça que
c'est ça qui asphyxie une partie du
débat démocratique et que c'est la
raison pour laquelle je dis comme
parlementaire franchement il y a une
ambiguïté quand Debré dit c'est un
régime parlementaire oui parce qu'il
faut avoir une majorité mais c'est pas
un régime dans lequel les parlementaires
sont en capacité de peser sur la
fabrique de la loi les gens pensent moi
je le vois dans ma circonscription vous
faites la loi régime qui répond à cette
définition c'est le régime présidentiel
c'est-à-dire le régime américain dans
lequel le Parlement le législatif est
complètement séparé du président et en
tous les cas mais sinon dans le régime
c'est le gouvernement qui décide jusqu'à
ce qu'il se fasse renverser mais c'est
l'exécutif qui a tous les pouvoirs
puisqu'il est le chef de la majorité ce
que ça terrible de dire l'exécutif à
tous les pouvoirs et tous les outils du
parlementarisme rationalisé du vote
bloqué à la maîtrise de l'ordre du jour
en passant parce qu'on vit en ce moment
le 49-3 à répétition c'est aussi
désespérant pour ceux qui ont porté des
députés aux responsabilités je veux
quand même du coup répondre à la
question pour moi ça c'est le cœur du
problème ce qui fait que comme on
n'arrive pas à aborder ce problème on
pense qu'on peut avoir des bouffées
d'oxygène que sont celles de la
démocratie territoriale qui est
importante aujourd'hui la France est une
République décentralisée et c'est un
point essentiel sauf que la tradition
qu'on peut qualifier de jacobine la
puissance de l'État qu'évoquait
Dominique Régnier suppose aussi un
moment qu'on se ferme pas les yeux sur
ce que ça signifie moi je viens de la
techno structure je sais que mes petits
camarades en cabinet ministériel ils ont
bien plus de pouvoir que moi
parlementaire et que tant qu'on sera
dans ce type de mode de prise de
décision alors on aura un hiatus
phénoménal on pourra le compenser par
des territoires qui peuvent essayer
notamment d'innover sur des pratiques de
démocratie participative de plus grande
horizontalité mais nous ne sommes pas un
État fédéral et c'est tant mieux voilà
ce qui me frappe beaucoup c'est que tout
ne se résume pas au Parlement à la loi
me semble-t-il et ça je crois que c'est
un autre sujet
française pour la loi je suis d'accord
la fascination pour la norme qui
d'ailleurs se reporte après sur la
volonté de réviser la Constitution parce
que si on prend d'autres régimes
parlementaires qui donc fonctionne avec
cette même logique d'un gouvernement qui
effectivement gouverne pleinement parce
qu'il a une majorité qu'il soutient
qu'elle soit relative de coalition ou
absolue mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que le rôle du Parlement est certes
d'accompagner le gouvernement pour la
mise en oeuvre d'une politique mais
aussi de contrôler
et c'est vrai que cette dimension qui
est vraiment ancrée y compris dans
l'opinion selon laquelle on n'a rien
fait si on n'a pas réussi à faire voter
des lois et aussi un autre une autre
facette en quelque sorte de la
spécificité française au rapport au
pouvoir de français alors il s'agit pas
c'est pas c'est pas le parlementaire qui
veut absolument avoir la loi qui porte
son nom mais au moins que la loi qui
pour l'essentiel est d'origine
gouvernementale c'est les projets de loi
qu'au moins dans la fabrication de
celle-ci le Parlement c'est vrai quand
il y a c'est déjà vrai quand il y a une
majorité claire voilà moi j'ai vécu ce
que c'est d'être dans une majorité à qui
on demande d'être godillot et de voter
la loi telle qu'elle avec un argument
politique et de dire si tu es député mon
gars c'est parce que le Président de la
République qui propose la loi il a été
élu trois semaines aussi semaines avant
toi et donc faut que tu sois le doigt
sur la couture du pantalon mais alors à
fortiori quand on est dans un système de
majorité relative et j'en reviens à la
pratique du moment où là soit ça fait
sérieusement en turbuler le système moi
je sais pas s'il faut une sixième
république parce que je suis pas en
effet un fan des noms pour les Noirs
mais par contre une pratique et
peut-être quelque changement
institutionnel il y a beaucoup de
pratiques qui peut s'arranger voilà
Boris Vallaud le président du groupe
socialiste il vient d'écrire à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale qui
nous avait sollicité il y a le brame
Pivet pour dire comment concrètement à
droite constant on peut quand même
mettre un peu d'espace de respiration
sur la maîtrise de l'ordre du jour sur
le travail des commissions sur bon et
donc on va voir parce que moi je pense
pas que ça tiendra ou alors on reviendra
des choses plus classiques et il y aura
une coalition la minorité relative
Renaissance aujourd'hui qui est le plus
logique salie avec avec la droite parce
que c'est ça
[Musique]
à vous écouter
laissez entendre que les conditions
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas les mêmes
qu'elles étaient à l'époque du général
de Gaulle mais si on prend le
gouvernement de Michel Debré comme celui
de Michel Rocard
tous les deux avaient des majorités
relatives ce qui n'a pas empêché de très
grandes réformes d'être accomplie si je
ne me trompe pas la force de dissuasion
nucléaire en 1960 c'était d'un
gouvernement Debré avec une majorité
relative si on prend la CSG avec Michel
Rocard c'était avec une majorité
relative pourquoi ce qui était permis
avant ne le serait pas aujourd'hui par
exemple une filière nucléaire
conquérante dans un cas peut-être une
très grande réforme des retraites après
tout un régime même si un régime bat de
l'aile est-ce que ça empêche de très
grands projets
je dirais par principe ça ne peut pas
les empêcher
mais mais dans la dans la réalité
politique et historique
si on imagine par exemple
une très grande filière nucléaire
ce que pour ma part titre personnel
comme citoyen je souhaite ça me paraît
adapter à nos besoins ça suppose de
mobiliser des moyens des ressources
considérables sur de nombreux budgets et
donc de faire de faire des choix et
d'arbitrer en défaveur d'autres segments
de la dépense publique pour compenser
c'est sur dépenses et et là évidemment
toutes les choses en général se fissures
voir ce fracture c'est nous n'arrivons
pas à faire rentrer dans nos mécanismes
institutionnels mais encore une fois ce
ne sont pas eux qui sont en cause mais
je crois que c'est plutôt un problème de
culture politique et c'est plus embêtant
ça serait forme moins bien nous
n'arrivons pas à faire rentrer la
nécessité de choisir d'arbitrer si toute
réponse que produit un politique c'est
l'augmentation de la charge publique de
la dépense publique ou des prélèvements
parce que il peut y avoir des
investissements privés sur des grands
projets mais enfin il faut il faut
l'accompagnement public il faut par
exemple il faut accompagner les travaux
qui sont nécessaires il faut accompagner
l'explication à la société enfin il y a
tout le temps c'est tout un énorme un
énorme
barnum de faire tout cela mais ça
suppose d'arbitrer nécessairement de
cesser de faire d'autres choses on peut
imaginer ça c'est pas impossible mais il
faut une discussion qui a une
connotation politique très aiguë par
exemple CD des activités non pas à
privatiser ça a été fait mais comprendre
que des entreprises peuvent prendre en
charge des activités qui ont des qui ont
des effets de service public peut être
une des solutions quand on dit ça vous
voyez bien qu'il y a une dimension
idéologique donc ça ça peut susciter des
oppositions voir des confrontations
léger des accords
sur ce sujet d'abord c'est pas du tout
la même chose enfin c'est pas du tout le
même nature la réforme des retraites et
un très grand projet mais on rentre pas
dans le détail revenir ce que dit
Dominique Régnier il dit il faut
arbitrer mais on a fait la filière
nucléaire
on a réfléchi avec une approche
comptable qui nous a conduit d'ailleurs
à des privatisations dont certaines ont
sans doute été heureuses mais dans
beaucoup on était très malheureuses
voilà pour pour la richesse du pays donc
mais on voit bien vous vous situiez tout
à l'heure le gouvernement Debré majorité
relative vous savez comment ça a fini
quand même je veux dire alors c'est pas
Debré parti pour pinou est arrivé il y a
la réforme de 62 le Parlement a voté
contre et de Gaulle a dissout Parlement
c'est la première la seule ma
connaissance
renvoyer le Parlement et le et de Gold
s'est retrouvé avec une majorité non
plus relative mais absolue Jérôme Guedj
sur cette question là c'est pas que je
vous mettes en
on a des accords avec les insoumis mais
sur la filière nucléaire sur la filière
nucléaire on a eu dans cette émission de
très nombreux responsables socialistes
de Bernard Cazeneuve François Hollande
etc ils ont ils sont tous favorables à
cette filière nucléaire vous-même sur ce
point vous restez sur cette vous seriez
favorable à ce que la France retrouve
une souveraineté énergétique grâce à la
filière nucléaire je suis d'accord pour
que la France retrouve une souveraineté
énergétique en y mettant la même énergie
au développement d'une filière des
énergies renouvelables qu'elle a été
capable de le faire les énergies pour
l'énergie nucléaire sacrifiant la
filière nucléaire où on l'a développant
moi je suis pas dans une approche
antagonique l'une de l'autre sauf que au
regard des moyens qui sont à mobiliser
force et de constater que ce n'est pas
ce qui se passe quand je vois qu'entre
2017 et 2022 la France est le seul pays
de l'Union européenne qui n'a pas vu la
part des énergies renouvelables
s'accroître dans la production
électrique je me dis que nous avons pas
été capable de dégager à la fois la
puissance de de
la techno structure pour le coup de la
recherche du développement que nos
industries sont capables de produire en
mettant la priorité parce que il y avait
amené de fronts les deux sujets donc moi
je suis pas pour arrêter demain matin le
nucléaire je pense que c'est un horizon
qu'on doit avoir en perspective que je
vais être très synthèse à la François
Hollande que la proposition de réduction
de la part du nucléaire dans la
production énergétique française doit
être notre notre objectif et qu'on verra
compris voilà donc plus le temps de
continuer mais si je vous pensez pas
qu'il y a eu un certain état d'esprit en
France qui a fait que la filière
nucléaire connaît les difficultés qu'on
connaît alors je sais pas bien
et la Cinquième République
considérer que c'est à dire que l'un est
l'une participent à un moment aussi de
ce côté
un peu cadré on va dire un peu il y a
pas d'alternative et de la même manière
que je suis pour de l'horizontalité dans
la 5ème République en repoussant les
portes et les fenêtres en les aérant un
petit peu pour quelque chose qui
pourrait ressembler à une sixième
république même si on la nomme pas on la
nomme pas comme tel et ben sur le
nucléaire je suis aussi pour qu'on y
mette un peu d'horizontalité diversité
dans la production il reste une minute
vous voulez dire un mot là-dessus sur le
nucléaire ou sur la nucléaire est-ce
qu'il y a une alternative à la Cinquième
République pour moi il y a toujours des
alternatives à vos risques on peut
choisir
aux gens de se prononcer sur multitude
de constitution je pense que ça serait
une erreur profonde la cinquième but
c'est une synthèse on parlait de la
monarchie républicaine mais c'est une
synthèse la France elle avance par
synthèse c'est-à-dire
l'Empire avec la synthèse entre la
Révolution et la monarchie et là la
synthèse entre la République et la
démocratie d'un côté et et un vieux sur
moi monarchique qui tient effectivement
au fait que ce pays s'est construit par
a été construit par l'État il a été
construit avec une figure du souverain
qui s'est imposée et qui a permis
l'unité l'unité de la France et que la
France est toujours pas tout à fait
remise de la manière dont elle s'est
débarrassée de la de la figure
traditionnelle de la souveraineté mais
c'est vrai et elle a elle est toujours à
la recherche
républicaine et c'est très bien comme ça
après tout le monde tous les tous les
après tous les monarques ne sont pas
d'une égale qualité merci merci Henri
Guenot il me reste à présenter mes
brièvement parce qu'on a plus de temps
une bibliographie alors je rappelle ce
livre demain la cinquième d'Hervé
gueymar et Arnaud Tessier nous avons
également savoir pour pouvoir sortir de
l'impuissance démocratique par François
Cornu gentil je voudrais signaler le
livre d'Henri Guaino de Gaulle le nom
mais le nom avec un M ne vous trompez
pas de tout ce qui nous manque vous
voyez qu'il est dans la nostalgie non
pas du tout non alors je voudrais
rappeler plutôt nostalgique mais c'est
pas une mauvaise un mauvais sentiment la
nostalgie oui disait la nostalgie c'est
le coup de pied donné
derrière des des amnésiques
Anne le Vat je rappelle que vous avez
dirigé un gros livre qui s'appelle
l'élection présidentielle chez Dalloz
Henri Guaino donc je viens de signaler
votre livre Dominique Régnier vous avez
publié beaucoup de livres dont les
nouveaux populismes je sais plus rien en
un mot mais vraiment monsieur Guedj
est-ce que vous avez un livre à signaler
un vieux livre qui parle des enjeux du
vieillissement de la population qui
s'appelle plaidoyer pour les vieux qui
était chez grassés il y a quelques
années et qui est toujours d'actualité
parce qu'il nous manque une loi grand
âge et autonome dans le pays sur lequel
on pourrait faire du consensus à
l'Assemblée nationale merci
il me reste à vous remercier merci
l'équipe de LCP et je voudrais avant de
vous laisser partir vous soumettre cette
citation la force de cette constitution
la cinquième c'est qu'elle permet
d'éviter la tyrannie de l'immédiateté
une absurdité contemporaine à votre avis
Dominique Régnier c'est qui ça cette
phrase
est tombé sur lui heureusement
vous voyez que la Cinquième République
distorsion entre les 5e a toujours des
défenseurs
qui s'appelait révolution mais
révolution souvent on revient au point
de départ voilà
il me reste donc à vous remercier voilà
un prochaine fois
[Musique]